thank you very much i uh
thank you so much i'm
so glad you're in a good mood because
i'm kind of down this state
fires droughts and now we have an oil
spill
have you seen this [ __ ] off it's right
off the coast here la residents are
furious the last thing we want is oil in
our sewage
you know
[Applause]
and then can we have a moment of silence
for the tragedy that happened this week
facebook went down on monday
the millennials and gen z oh my god
facebook instagram what's up they all
went down for six hours and i think as
americans we all will remember where we
were that day
when we couldn't take a picture of
ourselves in the bathroom mirror and
send it out
when we couldn't argue vaccine mandates
with our lab partner from seventh
grade when there was nowhere to post a
meme of biden and bill gates jerking
satan off it was a terrible day but
we're over it
it's over
and there is some actual really good
news i think covet cases they say are
declining precipitously healthbricks
health experts are saying we may be at
the beginning of the end of this [ __ ]
nightmare
please please jesus
no really they say keep your fingers
crossed by christmas airline passengers
may be back to punching each other over
the armrest
not everyone i'm gonna tell you not
everyone is on board with this there's a
state representative from new hampshire
guess which party
who is blocking covert funds because he
says uh babies
of vaccinated women are being born with
pitch black eyes and
they can stand and walk at three months
which
i don't think is true but uh
but honestly would walking babies be
such a bad thing
i'm sure there are parents out there
thinking you know what that would be
awesome
when the kid cries for milk i can just
say you know where the refrigerator is
get it yourself
like i would know but
and this guy also says
listen to this he says the vaccine
contains tentacled creatures
i think someone has been watching a
little too much squid game
have you been watching
not steve there's always a new stupid
show
that's the one people at squid game it's
about this hyper violent south korean
version i guess of hunger games and in
the movie or the series people who have
debts and can't pay them are forced to
murder each other
and mitch mcconnell said i'm listening
oh i kid i kid the rich
i kid the super rich did you see the
forbes you know every year they have the
forbes 400 list that comes out the
richest 400 americans 40
i mean of the 400 40
are richer than they were just last year
or they're 40 percent richer something
they're richer
i know it's [ __ ] up
but the republicans they always say a
rising tide lifts all boats to say
nothing of what it does for private
rocket chips
really that's those
uh
now it's getting
it's getting chippy out there did you
see what happened with uh kirsten
kersten cinema this week you know who
she is she's the arizona senator who saw
two of the senators you know democrats
are holding up their big 3.5 trillion
dollar program and a lot of people don't
like this so she was at arizona state
university at an event and a gang of gen
z activists
followed her into the bathroom
started yelling at her in the bathroom
while she was peeing
and then they went back to demanding
that we make campuses a safe space
yeah i think that's a little over the
top
they followed her in there and they were
recording themselves yelling at her
while she's in the stall
and she's like they're saying telling
her we're streaming live and she said i
am too get the [ __ ] out of here
you